So going back to our mani-core challenges, we have
seen that there are solutions to the increasing the
on-chip coherence traffic as the number of cores grows.
We have seen solutions to the increasing off-chip traffic
as the number of cores grows. And we have
also seen a way to have a directory that
will support our on-chip network and that solution was,
as we have recently seen, a distributed partial directory,
which doesn't keep information for every possible
block in memory. It only keeps information
for a limited number of blocks, and
has a replacement policy, and invalidates on-chip caches
as a result of such replacements. The
next mani-core challenge we will consider is that
the power budget available for the chip,
for example 100 watts that we can reasonably
call from a chip of the area that we can manufacture is split among all the
cores. So as the number of cores goes up, the power we can spend in each
core goes down. And that means that the
frequency and the voltage that we can use
in each core goes down. And that means
that if we have a single-threaded program it gets
slower and slower, the more cores we have. because that single-threaded program,
if we only had one core, would get the power budget of
the entire chip. With, let's say, 64 cores, it gets
only a 64th part of the power budget. So what do we do about this?